I'm in the Powerteam and I'm here for Dr. Seinyor 6000. Here comes my sisters.
Bubbles, I should be hosting now! Where was I?
Well, as we continue, Dr. Seinyor had defeated the evil brother once again and he's trying to destroy him again, this time Frieza.
Okay, are you ready?
And...
It's so big, look at your arms.
Because I'm older.
Stacie, come in here.
I'll be in this way.
I'm going to fish up.
While he's gone, I guess I'll just read my diary.
Hi, girls.
Hi.
I'll be right back.
I'll just use my...my, uh...
secret passageway.
Far and so far.
You be good for...your babies and your girls.
Adria, look for...Adria, look for the lightning.
How's the river so far, guys?
Oh, hey!
Scoop it out!
Okay.
We go this way.
And...
Hey!
What did you do?
I created my own thing.
What is that?
That's the donut with the...with the cherry on top.
And you created your own little chocolate planter.
What was...what did you do to me?
My hamburger, my cookie, and my cracker.
Thanks for watching.
See you next time.
What are you doing over there?
Tense points.
Tense.
Tense you have to nice.
Tense?
Um...Tense, he said, um...
My...
You're going to power speed.
These chairs are steady.
They'll be 100% by then.
And they'll be 100% powered.
You want some?
I'll be right back.
He...you and me should use...
Um...
Come on.
There we go.
Okay.
sharing your family...
After dinner, everybody in the car is going to take a nap in the rest of our house.
How's your dinner Bubbles?
Good.
Awesome.
Do you want some of my soup?
Yeah.
Oh, watch it.
That's some very special soup.
It hits the floor.
There are mushrooms everywhere.
I know.
And then we'll have a fire and then we'll have an empty truck.
And then we'll have the pizza.
Ooh, that's what I'm talking about.
Pizzas and a bunch of puedes, even the mushrooms.
It's gonna explode.
No it won't.
Oh, yeah.
We're eating mushrooms, but they'll be all over the walls.
Oh boy.
Busy.
I have a bad feeling about this.
I know.
I totally am.
Toilets all over the wall.
He's hurting me.
He's hurting me well.
Watch me look.
Hey, wait a minute.
Hi.
How are you?
Excuse me one more time, yes.
Just a little more homework to do.
Me?
I knew you would, Dawson.
There's only two files to sign.
There's a pillow in the middle.
Okay.
Is it taken?
Oopsie.
It's pretty loud in here, too.
Hey.
That's one of the keys.
Why the key?
I don't know.
I don't think you can open it.
This is it.
Let me go back inside.
Here, let's take a look.
How are you doing, mommy?
Hey.
I know.
How are you?
Fine.
You?
Let's go.
Well, you're already here.
We got it.
Okay, let's do that.
Let's go.
I think that was because I think he was not able to do it.
And then he was late and then he couldn't do it.
That's exactly what she did, actually.
I'm telling you that he's the only one who can talk about it.
That's exactly what she did.
You're the only one who can say something.
Coffee? I'm going to go take a little nap while we're at the AC style
and send the coffee to the doctor to treat me.
Dad, let me have my, um...
Let me have, um...
Copy all of Dad's files and get them to this computer
and then add the ones that you just got.
This morning, the doctor told us that you were infected by a virus.
Dad, can you stop the virus for a second?
The virus?
The test one. I never got tested.
But Dad, can you please copy it?
Please copy the virus.
It's not the virus. You're fine.
Worry.
If you ever try to copy files from your computer,
the virus will enter your computer and destroy all your files.
No.
Dad.
I'll leave you this later.
Should I copy it later?
No. The virus is protecting you.
So, we have to do this tomorrow.
No.
Dad.
Can I get a coffee?
The virus is going to protect you.
Okay.
Dad.
I'm ready to take a nap.
Are you girls?
Yeah.
Come.
I got the lucky giveaway.
I'll be back in a minute.
Hello?
Have I told you?
Every time, no, just, every time I'm the first one to go to the,
to the nap place, I'm always the last one?
I don't know.
Is this how it is?
No.
Stacey was the only one that got up.
I don't want to go to my car, I'm so annoyed.
Can you see?
You're doing this, Mary.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Well.
Copy Duckster's files again.
Stacey, take care of your napkin.
Ow, my head.
My head.
Stacey, why did you always put that pillar there?
What?
Why did you put that pillar there for me to burp my head on?
I don't know.
I put that pillar for you to sleep.
No, it's for you to burp your ass.
Well, I'll turn it no sound.
Ding, ding.
Warning.
The viruses, two viruses will come into your system.
Uh-oh.
Even worse.
Now this is going to be good.
I don't know.
Um, pretend Duckster didn't copy Stacey's files then.
Because she has five viruses guarding it.
Uh-uh.
Mm-hmm.
It's different.
I'll get that.
Huh?
Nothing.
What's in this one?
Adam.
Stacey.
My name is not Adam, Stacey.
I don't know.
Well, Stacey.
In your ear.
Stacey, I cannot listen to you right now because you're in a very disney mood.
Adam!
Blossom.
Stacey, why'd you run into the room?
Blossom, you came along to brush your teeth, too.
Are you Blossom?
I just suddenly became the last.
I know.
And you're probably going to say I shouldn't have followed her.
Especially Blossom.
And look what I found.
I put in it.
What do you want, Blossom?
She likes food.
Because you're a vet.
I know.
Except you're our only friend.
Sometimes we don't.
We've been fighting bad guys for weeks.
It hasn't rang in ages.
Stacey.
Um.
For a truck.
Just in case.
I got some snacks for the kids.
Oh.
They need them.
Well, Bubba's packed them, so.
Gotta go check the bank.
Oh, look.
The park's okay.
I'm going to go sleep.
Bury them.
I'm going to go get Bubba.
Take our pictures, Stacey.
Take a picture of the sand.
I need a blanket.
Man.
I can't believe the hotline hasn't rang today.
Usually it rings a thousand times every day.
For it to get all set.
Number one.
No, I don't, Stacey.
I need to get Blossom on number two.
I mean, number three.
Probably two.
You want just your back hair polished.
It seems like that's so shiny.
It looks like it's going to get all over the place.
I guess.
How come it got more shinier than it was last time?
Maybe it's because that's the...
To polish your hair, the teacher's favorite color is yellow.
There you go.
That's your only coat you need.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You need a paper towel.
Where's Blossom's paper towel?
Right over there.
That's the one that isn't broken.
Blossom, your hair is almost ready.
Bubba, we're going to do a little polishing, right?
Yep.
Nice and smooth and shiny.
You can take it off.
I'm going to say that again.
I'm going to smell this.
Oh, this is white.
That's Bubble.
And that is...
Cinnamon Blossom.
Oh.
And the pink.
Not the red.
That's green.
Okay.
Time to give her a second coat of green.
Bubbles, what are you doing with that?
I'm going to polish Bubbles.
Oh, your hair smells good.
Shoo.
I'm going to do the blue.
You smell Bubbles.
And then I put Watermelon on it.
Oh.
That smells good.
And I'm going to put Cinnamon on it.
Oh, no.
The red.
It doesn't smell good by itself.
The Cinnamon.
But with something else, it smells really good.
When it has two things with it, it smells really good.
Oh, I forgot to do your back hair, Blossom.
Sorry.
Hey, the big red bruises all over my hair.
Your back hair is all over my hair.
Oh, yeah.
I'm a real YouTube Polish fellow, right?
Right!
But I did get a real mark because I was playing basketball at school and I scraped my hair
and I made a red mark.
It's still there!
How many days was that ago?
Just today.
It's coming off, but it is making it sticky too.
Well, I'm going to have to give you conditioner after this.
Get your hair off.
I think we should really wash their hair.
No.
Spray bottle.
Spray bubbles into it.
Get ready, Blossom.
Oh, I got to get in the...
Okay.
Thanks.
Okay, come put your...
Go, Blossom.
Now time to put your conditioner to work.
Okay, and Adam, after you're done that, hand it to me.
Adam, how...
Oh, man.
So beautiful, Blossom, of that conditioner.
So is Bubbles's.
Adam, can you squirt down bubbles?
Digger, you have to keep squirting it until it drops over here.
You only need...
You only need three drops.
That's what the...
I'm rubbing it on there.
But this is the kind that comes off.
I need that.
What's stuck in this?
Nothing.
Yes, you did.
Oh, I'll get like a tiny...
You don't do this.
To make it shiny.
Because that's what they do.
That hair massage cream feels so good.
Why don't you try it on, Blossom?
I mean, I am doing it.
I am feeling it.
Okay.
I'm going to use my bare hands.
Because that's what they say or it will come off right away.
Okay, Blossom.
You better get your hair to dry.
Time to wash off.
And I think it'll do it.
Doesn't it really smell like bubble gum?
Yes.
It's good for your play-doh.
It makes them round.
It'll be attaching.
And you shouldn't do it until I'm done.
Here, pause.
Don't do it or it'll turn yellow hair on you.
But the hair will turn brown, and Bubba doesn't want her hair to turn brown.
She wants it to stay yellow.
And if it turns brown, she's going to punch the person whoever did it.
But if it's during the tenure, she'll just scratch them.
What good is that?
Now, can you put the stack in after Bubba's hair?
Dr. Schnorr, the name is Dr. Schnorr.
I said.
I said, daughter, hello.
Huh, you didn't know me anymore?
Stepdaughter, I think.
Say mine.
Look at that.
Your hair looks so beautiful.
Cause I found out.
How's the massage?
First I put their hair like this.
Look what I did.
It's a slingshot.
And watch out.
Right there next to your hands.
Oh, don't, don't, don't.
Oh, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
Here.
I'm not.
Da, da, da.
Book's still on the table.
I was studying last night.
Whew.
Let's shoot around the house.
I'm gonna try to get all the security behind us.
Yeah, you can all.
Mm, it won't show up.
I gotta go help you do this stuff.
Why?
Just because, you have to.
I'm not going.
What?
Cause I have to take care of Bubba.
Do you care about the house?
I have to take care of Bubba.
What's more important?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Let's go find the microchips.
Boy Stacy, I can't believe we have so many big computers.
I don't even believe we have so many chips.
You know them.
Blossom's already sleeping.
Blossom's already sleepy.
She's the, sleeping.
She's the best girl in this house.
Bubba fell asleep before Blossom.
Ugh.
So the girls are the bestest girls in the house.
Yeah.
Who's the baddest?
Who?
Patty.
Yeah.
She always pushes the peas around.
Poor peas.
Where's this disk?
We thought it was open.
We could all move on.
We were wrong.
Disk?
Yeah.
What does the color do?
Oh boy, that computer.
I can't tell you what it does.
I know.
It trips down.
It goes crazy.
Peter, talk again.
Security activated.
Okay.
We'll get the security out of it.
Yes!
Get ready.
I'll see who's at the door.
You should be sleeping.
Blossom, you need the buttercup.
It could even be on you.
Can we jump too?
We're just sitting here quietly.
We're not touching anything until our bobbies and daddies come back.
It doesn't sound like it ought to be fun.
Oh, it's the dirtiest, poopiest, chubbiest place.
Promise.
Do you really promise?
Now you're always the best girl.
But Chucky, I don't.
Can you just get to sleep?
No.
Yes, we do.
Did she get partied out?
I can't talk, but we can understand her and she can understand us.
She's hungry.
The kitchen.
Okay.
What are you doing in the other room?
Baby, find.
Oh, I forgot to give the girls some cupcakes for tonight's dinner.
Oh, here's one.
Okay, Buttercup.
You all right?
Here's yours.
You're going to the living room.
I'm making my own special bread.
Where is wumpa fruit?
Got to have wumpa fruit.
We don't have wumpa fruit.
We only have red and blue one for her.
Bubble gum!
Bubble gum?
Yeah.
You can eat that.
Put that CD back in, I'm sorry.
Some Everything Nice would be good.
I want to see Everything Nice.
The name is Dr. Snow.
I know.
Or a bunny.
I think she wants a red gem.
Well, it's Cherry Drop.
Does she like Cherry Drop?
Yeah, Cherry Drop.
Does she like Blueberry Blast better?
Yeah.
Let me get myself one.
Does she like Blueberry Blast better?
Yeah.
Then she gets the bubble gum.
Okay, time to get in the living room.
Yeah.
I know.
What are you going to do tonight?
I don't know, Dad, but I'll be in.
Oh, boy.
Don't know.
You said you have a problem.
Why don't you go get your own food?
Okay.
But don't get the one on the pink chair.
All right.
Okay.
I'll set it up for you.
And my recipe is a strip.
It should be good.
Whoa!
Sorry for rumbling the action.
That's okay.
Dad.
It has whipped cream and a cherry on top.
Yeah.
If I don't have any pizza, I'm going to blow my head.
Blow your head?
Yeah.
Never heard of that.
I don't know.